the jurogan experience what
what happened um with uh with the
dissident
um is you know the
the film is kind of the untold story uh
behind the murder of jamal khashoggi
you know the the washington post
journalist
walks into the saudi consulate in
istanbul in
october 2018 and uh
is murdered uh i mean just the most
horrific
ghastly murder um they uh
he walks into the consulate um they
basically
you know strangle him start embalming
him as he's alive uh
and kill him and then bombing him while
he was alive
yes because they wanted the blood to
coagulate because they then dismembered
him and
caught him into pieces to get him out of
the consulate
and uh you know and this was ordered by
muhammad bin salman the
you know the the crown prince of saudi
arabia that's proven that he ordered it
well yeah i i think we have to
go and say do do we believe the cia
do we believe british intelligence
french intelligence
uh do we believe turkish intelligence um
turkey um there was a listening device
in
in the consulate um we don't know how
the consulate was bugged
but it was bugged and so the entire
audio of khashoggi's murder
and even the planning of his murder
was captured by the turks
and
i obtained the transcript as part of
making this film
and there were independent
investigations conducted agnes calamart
of the u.n
of course the turks cia
and all of them concluded with a very
very
high level of confidence that mbs
ordered the murder and if you understand
how saudi arabia
works right i mean this is considered an
absolute monarchy this is an
authoritarian regime
right and you have probably 90 percent
you know and i'm making up this
statistic but something of the entire
wealth of a country controlled by one
family so the idea
that you could send 15 people
on private jets owned
by the kingdom of saudi arabia traveling
on diplomatic passports people
in the kill team uh one of the guys was
uh
mutreb who was muhammad bin salman's
you know personal security had a
security
other guy was altobazi who is the state
forensic examiner and coroner who came
with a
bone saw another guy alice siri
is one of the top ranking generals
and the list goes on and on and and so
the idea that you could
have this carried out without
the approval of the crown prince
would be staggering to believe
i mean it's it's it's next to
impossible because who else would order
this crime
and especially when you're dealing with
it with an absolute monarchy
um anybody who did this without that
sort of permission right i mean
that's this is uh you know saudi arabia
carried out
800 beheadings last year so
talk about off with your head i mean
everywhere i go they might not recognize
me
but then if i they say hey what are you
doing i go oh yeah did you see icarus
i mean everywhere i go in the world they
all saw it
like i i can't even find people that
haven't seen it at this point
i mean it's it feels like the whole
planet watched it
and that is the extraordinary power of
netflix that when they put out a film it
releases into like 197 countries
across like 50 languages all at the same
time
the entire world has access to it
and the entire world should have access
to this film
but they're not going to have access to
this film
because there are business interests at
stake
there are investment interests at stake
and
and that is really disappointing
and so i'm
shocked that
that i believe with great wealth
and with great power comes great
responsibility
and if these
business titans
that that have these huge
companies lose
their moral compass lose
their direction to basically
say okay this might not be the very best
thing
for our business or our subscriber
growth
but god damn it people should see this
wow we got to do something about it
wow there are people losing their lives
and sitting in jails
and maybe our distributing this film
can change that maybe our letting
our hundreds of millions of subscribers
see this can actually bring about
positive change for humanity
and they don't do that that's really
it's it's it's soul-crushing
i i got a a message and i hope hatisha
is not going to be mad at me um
she his fiancee
sent me a message
to two
two days ago and
she said hi dear brian i've read all the
reviews
of the film and i'm very encouraged
they seem to like the film and they have
a really good idea about it
the main three points they mentioned is
that you're brave
that omar struggles and my position
is fighting for human rights
i'm glad i'm proud of you every day
you made history you did an incredible
job believe me
all is well now i'm getting better every
day
this trauma has created a new hedesia i
think
i understand that every day i'm not the
same person
two years as i was two years before
i got a lot and i learned a lot and i
made some good friends
the most important one is you and your
team
thor that's thor halverson the president
of the human rights foundation who
financed the film
and jake swanko he is my cinematographer
my life changed and my opinion also
changed and my daily life also changed
the one thing that did not change is my
love
and my heart it's still full of love for
humanity
and jamal's soul i believe that if we
change life
it will be with love and with love for
our values
and that's extraordinary to me to see
that his fiancee two years on
has such that incredible positive
outlook
on in war in the world and i'm so
honored to receive that message
and at the same time you know
i know that for the world to actually
learn of her story and her fight for
jamal's life and for justice
um is going to be a struggle
because of the uh um
whatever you want to call it business
interests
of these major platforms that come ahead
of seeking any sort of accountability
for human rights abuses and the
potential
to make the world a better place and the
potential to make the
world a better pace but it might not
align
with their goals for subscriber growth
in that region of the world or it
might not coincide with
possible future investments or
investments
or shareholder value and
that's that's unfortunate it's
unfortunate if the
richest man on planet earth or now the
second i guess
uh jeff bezos uh is more concerned
with his bottom line than he is
concerned
about seeking justice and accountability
for
a man who worked for him
who was murdered while working for his
newspaper
and that he and his company
could have stepped forward to see to it
that the world truly had access to this
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience